what is up everybody happy Tuesday it is
time for another gratitude journal live
stream number 12 today go go gadget
gratitude super excited to be here again
today uh we've got ten minutes together
and again the consistent message here is
that gratitude is an important part of
your happiness of your success it's
being equally you know frustrated and
wanting to move forward and accomplish
your big goals but also being on the
other side really grateful for what you
already have because you have a lot more
than most people in the world do and
appreciating that is important for this
to be something that really makes a
difference in your life it has to be
something that you do daily it's
everyday is a consistent habit OOP
attention attention being that the
monthly URL Artest monthly fireman safe
disregard all signals that balance I
repeat this is only a test please
disregard all singles and sound thank
you all right disregard all signals and
sounds we'll see if we get interrupted
um yes it has to be daily for it to
stick and you have to feel it it's gotta
be something that when you think about
it you're actually in a zone that you
you know it feels your soul that you
feel really good that you feel warm and
fuzzy because if you just listen in a
second of work and so how this works is
I will share three things I ungrateful
for I want you guys in a live chat to
share three things you're grateful for
the people watching it after leave the
three things that you were great before
in the comments below and actually feel
it as you type if you do that
consistently you will be a much happier
human being and I think that's important
because entrepreneurs are the ones that
are going to change the world and we
need happy entrepreneurs they're gonna
go and accomplish the goals so I am up
first I'm really grateful for my team I
have about 20 people on in my main
business in Toronto and sauce we've got
10 people plus another 40 ish who are
helpers none of this happens without my
team
you know the team allows me to do what I
do and I'm super grateful for that I
think about the video side since you
guys watch the channel when I was doing
it all myself I was doing one video you
know a month in the one video week max
because I had to do everything and I
didn't enjoy most of it and then
bringing on an editor and bring it on
researcher and you know bringing on the
rest of my team helped me get to the
consistency that we're at now and allows
me to do what I love doing which is
sending a message being in front of the
camera and so I'm super good for my team
because I wouldn't be here without them
second thing for me is my believe music
playlist just music in general but
especially my believe music playlist if
I wake up and I'm tired or not feeling
well groggy had a late night whatever it
is one of the things that I do I wake up
I go to the bathroom and it then put on
my belief playlist and these are songs
that just make me dance that get me
going that you know music has a way of
instantly changing your state and so if
you're feeling unmotivated or down
gratitude can help the music can help
too and so I find that doing that daily
just music it does no like one song that
works music that makes you do this right
music that gets you excited and so I've
made a believe playlist its public you
guys can check it out but it's just my
own personal taste in music having
something for you guys every day could
be really helpful as well to change your
state and so I'm super grateful for
music I know we got some singers and
musicians here on the live stream so I'm
grateful for the art that you put into
the world and the third thing I'm
grateful for is the methodology in in
the book
I'm super grateful that I discovered it
I'm super grateful for the impact that
has had on my business and also on other
people's lives it just cuts to the core
of who you are a human being and the
conversations that I've had yes isn't
great like the book people reading the
samples and you know their their lives
you know changing and then realizing a
whole bunch of new stuff about
themselves and not having a plan but I
think about the people that I've gone
through it with in person people who are
trying to figure out their path they're
struggling with a business issue and
just how it totally opens up the world
for them and I don't you know like even
my journey of believe was a was a
struggle and took a long time to get
through and I'm just super grateful for
having discovered that and be able to
have the conversations that I've had and
seen people's eyes light up maybe the
first time in years fire alarm mmm-hmm
let's see how that it is see how that it
is that's it okay okay I'm gonna do some
shoutouts keep on the live stream I can
I can compete with the other is nice
alex is here now let's just muted it we
have a mute button okay J reyez we've
got four minutes on top of the beeping
thankful for inspiring opportunities to
give value for the keys and power of
smartphones for my parents who support
me even from afar from the entrepreneurs
of the world and all they provide I
think we're still be able to do this
with crazy fire alarms happening
anything for Alex being here to me you
want to say hi hey guys what do you
people for Alex what am i grateful for
ah Evan I'm grateful for Evan yeah I'm
grateful for Evan i doing always
stepping above and beyond which he needs
to because he believes there you go yeah
you're gonna win some fans over here you
know yeah cool haha Alex I R beard
buddies today okay next for precise
energized awakenings in the morning for
stock sites like videohive and pixabay
for so many things in life we she kept
TV I'm grateful for the people in my
life who really see me for my ability to
really see others that's interesting I
we feel that I have I'm grateful that I
believe in the unseen I'm grateful for
the mini food channel that I just
discovered on YouTube mini food channel
that's interesting what else good
morning good morning good morning how
did the meeting go lots of chatter
happening what else Daniel oh oops I
missed a bunch sorry YouTube's girls too
quick well we got a lot happening here
welcome everybody rajinder ray millville
much yes to music to dance hermosa I did
I have a daily playlist at a dance and
have fun sherry good morning Greenville
I found someone to enjoy life with I
love that what else what else what else
I'm sorry if I missed some it's
scrolling too fast bob is grateful for
life friends and family
alex is back to me next hi from Vietnam
hello what else Alex's new button isn't
working he's trying he's pressing the
button like crazy what else uhhhh much
I'm grateful for fire alarm to keep us
safe there we go grateful for the fire
alarms that keep us safe zeno grateful
for my running / jogging therapist
that's very interesting my lungs there's
a body part of the day and fire alarms
not this one though I love it I love it
what else Daniel grateful for you my
brother I don't be talking about me of
that so then I appreciate that Daniel if
there's somebody else then that's
awesome too rajinder anyone guess what
is the source of inspiration of Evan
know what do you guys you guys can guess
it up drink the drink this drink alex
has this drink is the source of my
inspiration this drink is the source of
my inspiration uh Thomas I'm grateful
for my family thanking for my job and
thankful for my goals that's it guys
were at nine ten thank you for the
customized fire alarm version of this
drill it was enjoyable for those of you
who watch it after again make sure to
leave the three things that you agree
before in the comments below do it daily
it'll make a big difference in your life
I promise you thank you guys for
watching we're gonna head over to the
twitch stream to answer some business
questions while playing league I
appreciate you all have an amazing day
continue to believe whatever your one
word is i'ma see you soon